et enfin quand on lisait beaucoup sur le
tourisme religieux il ya eu aussi expo
67 les jeux olympiques désormais on mise
sur le culinaire et les festivals
pauvre royal le plateau-mont-royal et
vieux montréal sont des incontournables
pour les touristes d'ailleurs comment
ben montréal aux touristes l'ecri
quoique dans leur guide sur les choses à
voir donc c'est plus par quartier me
voyez c'est assez assez court sur le
plateau mont royal typiquement ya là un
paragraphe et sur le vieux montréal il
ya un petit peu plus on n'a pas trop
encore lui voilà il ya deux pages sur
les des points à voir à faire lui même
pas beaucoup on découvre le manche entre
2 et 5 8 millions touristes viennent
chaque année et après tous viennent
visiter ici comment il connaît ça c'est
une question de marketing de marketing
urbain et c'est d'abord la ville
on rapporte montréal la même façon
quelqu'un de chic du chic de new york
accueille les 2 via ne va pas chercher
la même chose par exemple vue moral peut
l'intéresser vous cru que quelqu'un de
permis
tourisme montréal fait venir 500 plus de
500 journalistes chaque année et ça
c'est sans compter les journalistes qui
sont invités par le grand prix par le
festival de jazz en fait ce sont eux qui
font la pub et ce sont eux qui font la
réputation de montréal savoir si
montréal est cool ou pas on peut être
proactif nxt et les débats
dans beaucoup de corps on paye partir
l'hôtel le tour de ville et dans
certains cas c'est juste d'envoyer de
l'information est pour nous
effectivement c'est quelque chose de
très très puissant en terme d'affluence
et une fois à montréal le touriste bon
pas tous va aller chercher son souvenir
et ce qui marche c'est l'orignal la
feuille d'érable est un petit peu la
fleur de lys mais l'orignal c'est
toujours numéro 1
ça a toujours été comme ça tous comme ça
comment va montréal est une question
vient personnel est elle plus ou moins
qu'avant et stephen a atteint lui vaut
moqueries
we have we had dauphin dirait qu'elle
est con différemment c'est vraiment un
cours par rapport à ce que j'ai vécu
c'est certain ça ne sera plus jamais la
même chose je dirais que maintenant
maria les plus fous qu'eux
pour le passé par nécessairement plus
excitant que le départ mais plus close
chaque époque a son mot real media
l'ingrédient qui changent pas c'est
certainement le succès de montréal ce
sont ses habitants mais ça il fallait
dire que ce qui reste secret
oui
ça